you
we unmuted okay now we are gonna have to
do dude ok boys are welcome to the
Friday review of games everyone I as
always am E&E Lewis I am Dan Galpin and
I have a very special present for Dan
today they we are we are drinking uh say
it oh it's easy cuvee do jacco van i
would say maybe sounds good that's close
enough it might be Flemish so i might
ask rato he's foreign exactly how do we
pronounce this yes conveyed this Jekyll
Benz yes baby okay all right do we get
the rato cam rato cam oh all right I'm
just saying a black void that's good
because next next week we can suck less
and we can get the right okay there you
go so I got to say something about this
beer because in you know I don't want to
like here you can have the open one um
oh nice Rachel cam to cam yeah okay you
can just see just a little bit of big
Pete yeah so the thing about this beer
it's it's a sour flemish ale flemish
sour red ale I it is apparently has a
cascade of beautiful complex flavors oak
barrel aging for 18 months etc etc
vanilla it's all about the vanilla note
actually our pneus this is really really
sour beer this is like I've had sour
beers before and they were like you know
they were like lemonade or so this is
the warheads of beer this is yeah this
this is but but but it also has such a
delicate and complicated flavor I think
of it like a champagne or almost maybe
even a whiskey of beer you know except
it isn't it it's like dream little no no
yeah I don't know it's just just just
that whiskey's complicated not yeah it's
a very very complicated flavor I'm wine
hey I've had that and I would say it's
kind of like a wine yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah absolutely all right
yeah I just complex like that all right
thank you so if you uh if you happen to
watch the Friday app clinic last hour
you'll notice that I was there along
with rato mm-hmm because i'm a big
proponent of podcast apps I've never
found one that I liked still haven't but
hopefully we plant some seeds you know
what I'm looking for now again my my
twenty dollars or York you want to do a
Kickstarter I'll give you a hundred
bucks course you'll have to give me
something for it oh yeah absolutely i
would i would totally go for a transport
control that doesn't suck and something
that I always plays whatever is buffered
up instead of failing randomly because
my internet went away yeah absolutely
yeah you if that was like your hundred
dollar Kickstarter offer i would totally
go for that all right anyway all right
so the the point that I'm making is that
was I played with podcast apps dan
played with game so I'm just gonna kind
of sit back here and let him advertise
EA yeah so I wanted to say that I am
absolutely not wearing this because of
any other reason other than the fact
that EA gave it to me this week and it
just happens to be that we're doing
sports today so I figured wearing ed a
sport they can go and we are not doing
any EA titles because we're nominated
right they're not good titles I actually
I really like both the soccer and
football but you know we are here to
look at the things that people nominated
on the moderator page and we have a very
eclectic set of games it of course is
the Olympics are still technically going
on so but we don't know it because we
don't have cable subscriptions and all
we get here is NBC hey yeah and we do
have a lot of YouTube live streams going
out there that is actually how I've
caught all of my Olympics that I've seen
this year it's on youtube so thank you
to the folks at YouTube who made that
happen and let's talk about what we have
today so we've got a really wide variety
of games we have a everything from what
I would call kind of simple shoot you
know were they would they replicate one
mechanic of the game really well to
actually at the end we actually even
have a olympic-style old
our game style remix game nice kinda
cool but I played that for hours in
junior high absolutely this is one has
touch controls and it's pretty cool they
all a lot of these games that need some
work but it was great to see such a wide
variety of stuff I was expecting you
know golf games and soccer games and and
we didn't get any those so no footballs
and all now no no we so you got it we've
had a couple of weird do you think it's
just it's a football games on Android
suck because it feels like it feels like
the screen would be really good for
football yeah I mean we've to exactly
football you know Madden is great and so
is a gameloft title real football or
whatever they're both really good to get
good ratings uh and I mean soccer very
similar we've got three great soccer
titles actually on on Android so yeah
not quite sure why but I think people
wanted to play with other stuff we did
actually sort it we sort of have a
soccer title in in a name our game which
is kind of awesome if you are a fan and
and if you are a fan of football of
course you are fan of Neymar I probably
pronouncing it wrong is it mrs. name or
knit I don't know I'm terrible at names
alright so let's start off with the
first one this is start and this is kind
of an interesting game because it
actually is a game it is a multiplayer
game and you challenged random people uh
nice points it's free star points
interesting uh okay all right uh play
online you want yes I have logged in
through openfeint already for you not
that I'm a huge fan of openfeint and but
anyways though the goal of this is is is
is is is to shoot basket and I had first
thought that actually the gravity of
said planet would affect this but it
doesn't as far as I can tell well that's
boring yeah it's just that like it is
such a however you know it's fun it's
fun to see a kind of fun presentation of
all of this and it actually uh there are
there actually are three basketball
games that we have that all have the
same shot mechanic this one just sort of
takes it out and to kind of the farthest
crazy extent with the real-time network
challenge here I'm really sucking you
this I'm sorry people but yeah I was
gonna say with the with the amount of
hints that you get for this it seems
like you should be doing better yeah the
missions I in theory played it before
you actually got on the air here right
but you also there's York you're
actually one of the goals is you want to
get all four of the backboard pieces
there that turns you into this sort of
fiery mode which I will try to show you
here I missed again so close I know now
I'm actually hitting baskets trying to
hit the bat I hit the backboard come on
152 no that's not gonna happen yeah oh
come on totally second yeah there you go
and lay all right now we know we're now
we're in like in like flame happy mode
here on the baskets we're doing swish
anyway so this is actually pretty fun
game on some general comments of it we
do see that I would like to see some
higher resolution artwork for the static
artwork the font is definitely blurry
here on the on the transformer prime and
that's one of the very the number font
here at the bottom and that's I think
that's intentional i think that's
actually got it because look at the
number front of the top I know I know
but it's still it's a combination of
both blur and and I mean there is
definitely I think yeah there's a little
bit of blue mada bloom on it I know but
I would still like to see it a little
higher res definitely with some of the
text but overall the presentation looks
really nice in this category of games
it's good the back key is actually
handled quite reasonably here and you
can see I go right back into my tonight
session here where we get to see how ah
right there at the end get to see I rank
and the rest against the rest of the
world they are so oh that's not bad that
that screen is a little busy but the
information is good yeah I think part of
this is also you'll see there's some
places in which text overlaps and stuff
like that some little details here again
we got really blurry looking icon I love
how they have openfeint yeah a blurry
openfeint yeah and heyzap and Twitter
and Facebook yes and whatever at sign is
yeah is that a new thing is that
something the kids are doing that I just
don't even know about maybe sherry now
yeah it's every male so interesting um
whoa are not using the shower until I
know you should be really not using a
share intent there I think at that point
so I definitely comment on that yeah
it's nice that does not have the
openfeint menu the problem with not
having a menu key and open faint is
there is no way for me to change my
profile so I am forever player 1854 7400
73 thank you open think we're not having
a button
do anything in my settings it's weird
that you know in a year they haven't
changed that I know I know I can't you
know so anyways normally you need a menu
key and actually in order to actually go
and make those changes so I'm awesome to
see this game actually is is properly
supporting honeycomb and ICS without
without without having any kind of
compatibility but we'd openfeint it
totally sucks so open a fix your problem
please right all right that's just don't
like fun idea it's Charlie sure I
actually live I wanted to change it to
my real profile but it did not actually
work that was star dunk and yeah it's
fine i definitely see a little bit just
just a little bit of refinement there
but uh but other than that you know i
was i was pretty happy with that game i
thought it was really cool really cool
example of doing network play and doing
a tournament this is actually become
really common sort of an anonymous
tournament with a whole bunch of people
all playing against a single timed mode
I would like to see some sort of reverse
interaction actually I think with all of
that so we're going I'm going in the
next game right now which is ninja
volleyball and you what I think you can
tell here ninja volley is it I'm right
into the game and it takes me into the
last netting menu that I was in which is
kind of cool it's a little bit actually
strangely enough jarring if i'ma act by
actually back out of the game you know
the expectation is when i come back in
i'm actually going to probably be at in
front of the same place rather than back
to where i was so that's sort of an
interesting for you mean the same place
as in like not where you were is he not
wearing any i see so now we're back at
settings i don't know it's kind of
interesting you can this is actually
customize again this is just from a UI
perspective i just wanted to see well
this does definitely work it just it
would be kind of cool to make it a
little clearer how this what this
interface is actually doing it this is
hair and you figure out pretty well
these are both different hair
customizations and different colors it
is weird that it's just numbers though I
mean yeah like that that's that's an odd
you I it looks like a debug you I it
does actually looks like it looks like
we're testing it and then and so you
know i but but it's really awesome you
can actually create all sorts of
different cool customizations their team
the characters are good i want high res
artwork but you know it's in fact wire
has fought especially i mean as i said
mind if you know if you don't mind me
saying something about the font now i
know we we we were wrong last week
when we dist on the Real Racing guy or
the not real reason tiny racing guy for
using Comic Sans he was actually using
just a font that ripped off comic sans
the correct yeah yeah which is just like
yeah yeah it's like no I'm not I'm not
drinking colt 45 i'm drinking kind of a
cheaper version that tries to be called
44 exactly sure anyway i'm just going to
say this font it looks kind of like
comic sans yeah it does someone
definitely definitely is not Comic Sans
it's not exactly what they were it looks
like an unholy union between papyrus and
comics yeah it actually does remind me
of that papyrus quite a lot the the main
the main thing I would say is they're
trying to give a ninja feel here okay
this is not getting it this particular
font also these are just bitmaps so I
definitely like to see you know some
really cool work done on ya the truth is
I think there's be a rule of oh yeah
that's much better I'd like to see
everything use the font that says that's
used in bluetooth multiplayer come
sooner you go well i think that is
papyrus mean probably papyrus stopped
being exciting after karateka basically
yeah my my rule of thumb is in a game do
not use a font that comes free with
microsoft word it isn't just the wrong
idea absolutely yeah alright so we've
got a lot of different options here
there's there's league is actually
Bluetooth player coming soon but there
is let's get into the game let's get
into the game so what once again I you
know again this is this this is really
nicely imaginative gameplay here and you
actually get into playing the game what
you actually have to do is touch the
ball with your hand and because your
ninjas you move silently and quickly to
the spot where the ball is which is why
it's enjoyable to eat so I i love you
don't need any animation at all exactly
and I that is awesome of the concept
behind the itis died I love the concept
behind the game and I can be die you're
a ninja I I know I know well you just
because I'm a ninja doesn't mean I can
tap things correct not a very good najar
in this stock ninja fourth touch touch
to continue we see that was an
interesting one to popping up a toast in
the middle of your gameplay generally
not a you know to transmit information
better than popping the dialogue but I'd
love to see it actually well again and I
think actually the developer this game
course bought it a little bit with them
some of the critics
moderator page um saying that you know
they do actually have a lot more to go
this is this is sort of an elder quality
game right so and I'm totally impressed
when they've done with it honestly I'm
is fun it plays well it actually uses
gestures you don't just tap you actually
as you tap and then you can actually
come very clean with the Jets very very
close I definitely need you know some
cool some more tutorials work you can
see they're actually they're doing a lot
of things right already they're using
lights-out mode in the game I'm actually
navigates quite reasonably when you when
you're inside the game they're using
libgdx just need a little bit better
assets or tablets let's let's face it
these just aren't good 720p haces yeah
exactly there but it's really a great
start and you see it the backe actually
does do something reasonable here we are
back on our main menu and then we are
back out just kind of you like you'd
expect so yeah very nice better own a
good job ninja volley guys and yeah just
just keep going with that the next one
was really really interesting this was
basketball white and and this is a game
actually we looked at ages and ages ago
it's like this is this is an old game in
right there the start of the game is try
our new basketball game tipoff so I'm
like okay we've got to actually have
both right and kind of show where
they're going from this game uses like
all sorts of Android UI and it's
actually kind of ugly but but the game
itself is kind of it's kind of cool so
you see is this is not designed it all
for tablets you can see all that knew I
was doing their own phones and it
actually doesn't explain you how to play
the game at all in in the actual in the
actual game but you know it's exactly
exactly the same mechanics oh is that a
box2d net it might be at it's very
possible I'm not as awesome but yeah
they've done a they actually a really
nice job with this game inter and I
remember looking at this like a year and
a half or two years ago or whenever it
came out and being like wow nice job
indie devs that's kind of cool that's
kind of that's the old version of the
game and it's actually it's actually
pretty free of problems other than kind
of ugly non tablet UI and let's
everything you know one thing gets hurry
so when you do it when you have
something it has been optimized for
tablet um this is kind of what it looks
like you see all the buttons are over on
the left hand side they're all really
really small remember this is an mdpi
device so all of your text is going to
be really really small because the idea
tablets you want to fit more stuff on
the screen and the problem is in this
particular case we don't what we really
want is really nice big texts really
nice buttons that make sense and so this
is if you don't do any optimization
around tablets this is what you end up
with which again is quite playable and
it actually this game as network
challenge and all sorts of crazy stuff
in it but I just want to see more you
definitely see zoom you definitely see
the old net the old menu let's look
let's go to tip off which the game so um
which hang yeah it's it's a complete
this game this game is like a completely
different different kind on different
level of game compared to the original
it's really cool to see that they came
went from that to this and you know it
has leaderboard coins the only problem
is actually from a from a navigation
perspective there's there's a lot of
stuff that are still missing especially
when you're in the in the tutorial
there's a lot of problems and and it's
all kind of let's see if we can actually
so let's I think we're not going to be
in this tutorial level here so I'm not
good you're not going to get to see all
the all the fun stuff you see it's
actually the same game with just a great
presentation and I think this actually
shows kind of what it takes what what
the next level looks like you know I
mean really this is the exact same game
we saw before with just a ton of other
awesomeness in the presentation and I
actually I thought they did such a good
job on this you know going from where
they were before now so here we are we
hit the back key this is not bad okay
we're actually popping up a dialogue
with the back use hit wait the back
again and nothing happens okay and then
also we have this kind of interesting
thing there is this there's restart and
play the plate because it looks all
different than all the other options
here I did not even realize initially
that that meant that meant continue down
there at the bottom oh yeah it doesn't
well it's weird because it's it's
actually sort of a different color
scheme it almost looks like it's grayed
out like it's part of a backgrounds yeah
and it isn't active kept hitting restart
like i'm restarting i recently and that
was i did i did that even during the
tutorial i couldn't figure out like how
do i how do I continue yeah it's a
mismatch touch it is it's a totally
mishmash style so that I definitely want
to see that that changed there's a lot
of little tiny you I things here that
actually that could be that could be
altered to make it
better I mean as a very complete
tutorial which is slightly annoying
because the tutorial came across is very
very slow in the unfortunately in this
game and I don't have enough so I can't
show it to you but I would definitely
look at that but other than that you
know this game is looking really really
good a couple of weird back key issues
and then a couple little you I glitches
but Wow compared those to compare those
two games it's night and day in terms of
presentation and it shows you know the
difference between a a game that's good
in a game that's great and is going to
get featured is a lot of times it is
just presentation yes it really i'm sad
to say right i mean you'd like to
believe that you can just whip one of
these things out in a month in your
garage but no yeah no you can't and and
as a consumer that's not what you want
right but if you take some time to the
art right yeah absolutely by the way i'm
sorry i've seem distracted it's just
that i'm playing front only big win
baseball and my my my team rato like
sandwiches is about to play their first
exhibition nice nice well that's it and
that is true so on um we can have the
rach okay so next one we're going to
look at is is actually 90s baseball
Rachel like sandwiches sandwiches
sandwiches yeah is it yeah exactly all
right so um it's Lincoln trouble method
will do you so you've got your choice
you've got auto and semi auto I'm gonna
pick Otto here and no this is this is
actually Dianetics nine innings baseball
thank you yeah we do still see the
vestigial Menu key here too sad because
you know honestly guys how many times
have we talked about this I know I know
it's it's and I'm not saying like on
this show and I'm talking about in
person to you guys guys that made this
game exactly does it come to us game
right this is a contrast game so gone
limb from on to us dude talk to me
Oh get a base hit it's really good
because you know come to us is is well
known for is K titles yeah k baseball
which are like all these really really
cute like little kids playing baseball
right and this is this is there a more
realistic title which I I think appeals
to me more you know I don't know I think
it's more of an American audience type a
title totally and I think they've done a
pretty good job yeah and this actually
combines two different mechanics in the
game that's actually so this the reason
why I put this game here is it actually
it actually combines a the sort of
arcade mechanic we see here with coke
with this tutorial which I'm going
through really slowly you see you end up
getting um cards and um who's Emma what
you had an Emma on your screen there she
is Emma M is my tutorial goddess really
yeah there's always some cute girl
telling you how to play sports apps in
these games Wow see there you are yeah
and you do see that this you know that
that was actually real other even there
even licensing like characters yeah
interesting and what doesn't actually no
she doesn't look like somebody who knows
a lot about baseball she looks like
she's a sort of like she's totally on a
webcam somewhere now on mmm eyes told
like I'm not being like sexist here it's
just that she kind of looks like she's
sitting in her bedroom on a webcam now
stealing home base that's hardcore I'm
stole home I I guess nice yeah exactly
don't forget to make it order for the
pitcher make this pitch alright well
anyways the point of this is is let's go
back they got her on my stock photo I
really do you think so i'm pretty sure
alright so you actually have cards you
actually end up with this box of cards
that you can manage and you know that's
cool and so this is actually it sort of
combines actually a lot of what is going
on in in an arcade baseball game you can
actually you can actually buy i'm not
going to do buy cards you can enhance
and mix cards and then you can play the
game no no tutorial
haha first of all on screen back key ah
alright but at least the back he does
actually work which is good so let's do
yeah we have this conversation with a
lot of people because they'll say well
you know apparently we we did some tests
and people really like to have a bakkie
on screen as well our response is
usually well a those may not be your
most hardcore android users and be the
whole point is to use a consistent you I
so so that we get everybody educated to
use a particular type of you I but you
know whatever if you don't want to get
featured go ahead and put screen back
but exactly so you can see here actually
what's kind of cool you sort of have
this combination only I'm elected to
only play offense because I don't
actually want to play defense in the
game and you know again we're in kind of
simple mode the game has all sorts of
different modes as I designed to please
different kinds of users and that's
what's actually come that's what's
actually cool about the game is it's
really it's just got super deep mud I
would say this arcade system is not
particularly deeper they even have two
levels of RK you can get this is like
the simple arcade and then they have a
complicated arcade the one thing they
don't have is going all the way out ware
big win baseball goes where it just
allows the game to play itself and then
please you can go all the way I'll to
play through the game like this again
you can say i'm going to play through
this much the game and see what happens
boom boom so it's now it's just doing
basic stuff you can actually watch it
play out it's not as the the you know
again this is just really really simple
in terms of presentation when you're
actually watching the gameplay but it
gives you that kind of card game
mechanic which is which is kind of cool
and you can see my players are sucking
none of them are actually make scoring
but you can sort of watch this you can
even skip this whole thing and skill
right there back to where i said and
let's let the game calculate a self out
there we are my team's doing pretty well
so even if all you like to do is manage
baseball I'm you just want to manage the
last couple of innings you can actually
do this you can play the arcade just the
last couple of innings so really cool
however you want to play
you know to play baseball with you want
kind of a full experience or partial
experience this game has it I totally
make sexy the den can I borrow your
credit card no wait that's okay I've
actually already got it I was gonna say
we're good for your famous actually
actually you're you're you are
supporting by yourself hothead games i
believe so yeah so I'm well by Google
self anyway yeah yeah yeah um so in any
case I don't want to go too far too much
farther through this game up obviously
the biggest problem with it is it just
not an android game I mean it just it
just needs to have the UI slightly
customized for android I definitely want
to see higher resolution artwork
especially in things like these buttons
we just kind of ashamed because you've
got you've got the images the image is
actually scale really really well and
that's what we've seen images scale
really well things like the buttons you
can see these edges um it'd just be nice
give us some high res artwork give us
some higher res font and the game will
look just that much better um so that
that would be my you know my if I were
going to say anything but basically make
sure the back you worked everywhere man
right how many times we said that yeah
that'll get you nailed for the the
google play store when they do featuring
they have a QA process ago too and
they're the QA people will go through
every screen and try to get bet the back
yeah yeah yeah I'm just like aah it's
just dumb stuff like that right I think
it's really frustrating when it doesn't
work yes exactly so bomb we're not going
where to go contrasting that too big win
based on a big win games are kono let's
let's put on the phone actually I know
the truth is this this game plays a lot
better on the phone it really does
because um because there's no action
there's nothing where you have to move
your hands around really fast um pretty
like is too wide put it up on baby
you're opening a starter pack and i'm
getting my platinum players going no i
want i want okay i don't know you know
what you know what did Dan you just do
what you know as soon as the starter
pack opens I want to go buy one to go to
yours for play but I do want to show
people to contrast the presentation
right yeah absolutely the presentation
in this game is really professional yeah
look at that you know all the animation
you can see though also all of the fonts
are just beautiful there
outlines they're actually very close to
resolution starter pack themselves a
little low there but all the rest of it
looks really really sharp and that just
makes a huge difference when you're on a
tablet like this and as you can see it's
you know from it from you know a tablet
perspective they're doing a pretty
pretty good job you know they're
actually using the keyboard which isn't
bad I've got whiskey rebels yeah yeah go
ahead I've got the keyboard down right
exactly oh that's why oh are you gonna
spell whiskey with Annie yeah is that
the kind of whiskey you like haha big
Pete begs to differ I know all right
that but I more American whiskey here i
think you mean merkin American whiskey
all right so we get we get to select
cards any any any suggestions here oh
you know it all just make sure you use
all three of them yeah that's a good
point it does so the only thing i don't
like about big win baseball compared to
let's say big win hockey as you know i
went nuts over too many players yeah 10
players manage yeah yeah starting lineup
for hockey is five players it's a it's a
lot easier to fill them all with
platinum it's a lot easier to remember
who they are this is a lot but well
baseball in general is kind of a kind of
a complicated game to manage I think
it's part i mean when i think about
baseball I mostly think of where's the
garlic fries so I'm probably not the
target audience here yeah but the garlic
fries are really good actually he's a
writer friend bucks on on big booster
yeah well you know and they are right in
the little Gordon beer stand right right
on the right on the left hand side of
paca 508 deeper I go there all right
it's a deal actually oh really no oh you
can't easily get you team um so uh yeah
but you know again the presentation is
really what they have done an incredible
job with this in this game yeah you know
as you know um earlier on in my career I
I did sports kids from Microsoft and I
remember those something that we we
spent a long time I try to make things
look like like like a network broadcast
all of this presentation is really
really good especially for a such a
small game
yeah you know they know the camera
motions the animation the sliding in and
out the crispness of the graphics yeah
it's all just really really high it's
very well done for what it is I mean
it's not like a full-blown three
baseball like we've seen but you know it
but but for for what they're doing with
you know sort of 2d with a little bit of
you know transformations on the it's
quite good um I mean you know again this
is this is just a card game um but
people who really like to manage
baseball it gets a little closer to that
it's not a realistic game in any sense
it really is a card game that has
baseball stuff thrown into it well it's
really fun about this is so we're
watching a game right now and the truth
is what we're really watching is a
computer simulation I the outcome of
which is known as soon as it starts yes
but the fun thing about watching it is
first it is fun they do some nice things
with the graphics they but more than
anything else they show you what your
players can and can't do and where they
screw up I have a beer in my hand and
I'm watching the tablet play baseball
this is like it's like yeah right
awesome yeah all right now I'm which
camera too I know really all you can
come on that man this build all of my
t-shirt um drinking problem I know true
all right so anyway um we can skip this
you skip at any time the value of
watching it is so you get to see where
your where your team members are
screwing up mm-hmm okay so I'm gonna
keep kicking people's asset big win
baseball I'm gonna continue with the
other games you bet all right so um so
in general this game also has occasional
issues with backe mostly where they
couldn't figure out what it would do
right and again figure out what it will
do make it do something all right let's
go into comedy here uh this is I'm have
to rotate the screen on this one we're
doing comedy games if this is nice this
is this is a a it is a sort of a sports
game on this is this is anymore it's a
fantasy game yeah and you're that's who
I want to be right there the goal is to
keep it oh we're not getting out put
hold on there we are now you guys are
it oh yeah they're not seeing it oh
there now they are okay that's what I
mean I oh yeah this is great this
totally reminds me of like arcade games
from 1985 Yeah right with you know when
they first got video into him this isn't
it oh sorry it's a name our game how do
you pronounce a name so I've got to
don't you recognize name are you only
their feet on no I bought hero I know
anything his guys yes he is the nut ball
football all right just basically in the
world today we call about soccer here in
United States right right yeah yeah here
in the United States sure yeah hey
women's soccer just won the gold in d
Knights fighting it for us and it was
kick ass by the way you saw those now
awesome but those against UK in Japan it
was it was it was they were really
amazing that isn't snoozer some
seriously tough women that's all I have
to say and they did an amazing job so
any was your God job is to keep the ball
alive I wouldn't really call it a soccer
game it wouldn't really call it a sports
game but it is sort of sports-related
and it's kind of fun it forces a sport
he's like seven animations and ensure
you're doing it with a with a soccer
ball but you could be doing with a hacky
sack and then it would be the national
sport of all like old people in China so
hey down there dude you and I alright
let's let's let's go on that's cool I
it's totally I would play that to the
biggest problem of this game and i'll
show you is it actually uses a
permission which i really hate people
using which is perhaps system walk so
now I now hit hit the button again and
open back in the game oh yeah that's a
little annoying because you'd think that
when you when you close the screen
especially somebody like you dan where
you will you will frequently play games
in the middle of conducting extremely
high level secret conversations
absolutely we have the nuclear launch
codes on your laptop you have the the
code to Sergei's Batman layer uh we
don't want those things stolen no
absolutely and besides about we all know
that Larry is Batman let's be able t
let's be the you know it's Sarah sure
gets too obvious he makes he's more like
Alfred he makes the toys so you do
realize that
that was a secret right there was like
the cmas direct thing going on now
you've just like everybody out you know
what we're gonna get kicked off and do I
mean yeah I do you're always here Larry
talk these days you know you know yeah
exactly okay keep this upcoming you guys
off all rights right way do we really be
cut off no um so uh Daniel just needs to
go to the bathroom again all right so
this is a good game but it shouldn't ask
for that permission that's dumb yeah
don't get out and also the game
continues to play underneath the lock
screen when you lock it so the hell we
couldn't figure how to stop it so we
just did we're not all you're a lot
we're not gonna lie you to lock it no
don't do that that sucks oh my god oh
god I just so guys I want to go on
record as saying and I'll just sort it
to the Heartless up actually can you put
the device cam on the phone yeah yeah
okay yeah what does that say Dan it is
five point five percent okay and how
much is left about two-thirds of the
bottle I rest my case next game I keep
saying that I'd be doing more the
talking no no you're supposed to do more
of the talking okay the next one is
tunes 2000 2012 Summer Games which
displays that you say 2012 is that okay
I think so are you sure yeah um and
games I know that's a good question I
think there's some jackbooted thugs out
there that want it okay let's uh little
moving right along so let's see this
thing already got it all right so uh oh
dude is this like that that old
hanna-barbera cartoon li na this hi I'm
ugh Lexi we need to cheat I really love
this game is so that I loved summer
games right right nice out as good as
winter just sad points about this game
one is it world challenge rather than
actually opening up a web view inside of
the game actually actually opens up a
web view outside of the game you know
you we could debate endlessly which is
worse but the point is they opened up a
web view come on ah it's sad but any
case oh um you know anyways UV we've got
we can go through here and we've got on
screen back buttons that you don't open
up a web view says by the way I'm just
gonna say this and I know
this will be a little bit politically
incorrect but opening up a web view
basically says we want to cheat people
on our payroll right I mean come on
you're you're like JavaScript
programmers mm-hmm you gotta you gotta
do that stuff yes let's do it native
come absolutely so here we are we have
an on-screen back button and we have no
support for the bakkie so like no good
they don't yeah right there they are
they are at least targeting SDK you know
version 11 or higher or whatever because
they've gotten rid of all of all of the
the Menu key that this is no menu key
which is good that's a good start and
let's see the game actually you know
what people are people are bored with us
harping on the menu key right a key over
and over again Thank You Robin any stuff
is it's this room you know it's like a
little email saying hey we didn't we
didn't actually feature you and here's
why and yeah exactly it's it's tough I
actually played the boxing game before
um so let's say let's do it all right
here we are and everything has is cute
it's a totally cute as I said the whole
game is cute defend okay defend and well
it's like it's like punch out but with
turtles yeah exactly so how do i attack
there we are hit ooh I like that you're
like punching turtles absolute a turtle
puncher he's a snapping turtle okay I'm
totally gonna owe me you know I ate a
turtle once and it was the saddest thing
ever oh cuz they brought it out with
like this little shell on and everything
and he looks so cute yeah I i I'm though
I remember going to the market sentai in
Taipei and actually seeing you know
partially recently oh man I just totally
died alright let's see another sport
that one sucked it looked good that in
it scale back bud doesn't work that
doesn't work anywhere in this guy don't
the home oh wow see what happens now
let's go there okay 23 games
mond come on do it all right um BMX a BF
weight is BMX a summer game it is in
their Summer Games all right can we play
dressage no they don't i don't think
they have to dodge okay oh wow awesome I
don't know what it was seriously this is
just like those cartoons we used to
watch our kids are like supposing Manila
gorilla or whatever is how uh this is
one of the oh sorry see every time I
pick up the tablet we lose hdmi oh oh
that hurts did totally are whew that's a
really small bike yeah anyways I really
love this game i want them to fix their
back key issues I which we could feature
tomorrow I mean to be honest I'm sure
you know it's unfortunately by the time
they fix everything in it the games are
going to be over what I love is the way
that this gorilla riding a BMX bike on
these random sandy hills is also doing
it in front of a backdrop of the London
skyline yes look it's the gherkin not
exactly look it's the London Eye have
you not been to London recently you
haven't seen the Great Sand Dunes a
Southland no I am NOT but then again I
never did go to South London there you
go yeah yeah actually actually actually
what we're just doing is we're we're
secret out we're down in what like in
like sex or something like that I didn't
absolutely so here's my here's my real
question rapist are you um are you
checking for people that are asking us
questions or braiding us or calling me a
racist on on my stream or are you
texting meme jen i'm reading memes and
eating a sandwich yeah I'm sure damage
it's fantastic sams a series great
really glad lifter treating you psycho
donuts proxy breakfast of champions I
bet indeed area are wait you're up I'm
trying to let your friend live there
this is you can't actually see what Dan
is doing with his hands but it's really
it's curious oh yeah nice ah it's all
over three yes yes no I'd lost I died
what a pity objective not reached all
right so what else do we have to look at
today all right I love that game we have
last one is Bobby volleyball okay and
once again presentation-wise there's a
lot of tacking this game and there's
just hack tech as all directors well
that's tech in this game okay um but it
just needs to be a lot of work on
present presentation there's nothing
worse than having this old-school font
then having this old tool fun with this
outline which shows how low res
everything is like that you know it
could be I mean it could be at home wash
feels like lucasarts in 1989 all right
we're gonna play again spots it's
actually kids came really does shine
them with its two player mode as far as
I can tell that's cool and yeah and
actually the game itself is really well
done so it's like the ultimate
distillation of dead or alive beach
volleyball yeah that it is wait but no
one would have liked their life beach
volleyball if it was if it didn't have
girls in bikinis right isn't that isn't
it I think they've captured the essence
all right I'm sure someone would like
actually I one of my friends loved dead
or alive also I do like the fact that
you're right you know my wife loved the
beach volleyball goodbye enduring
homeless also you can you can hit the
ball a lot yes I really want a point
this is really by the way we're um if
you'd like to help out with our show
we're looking for replacement for Dan
who can yeah yeah space them but it
comes down to alright so so tell us
about the game what are they doing right
ah so what they're doing right is they
actually have reasonable back keep mode
versus they actually and that's and the
game after the presentation when you
actually get into
itself is really good well they do is
obvious on getting everywhere to that
level um and it's kind of funny it's at
sort of ninety percent thing I think
they've actually done they've got like
they have support for Wi-Fi move Lee
yeah you know it's like it'd be great if
the Wi-Fi stuff could be will feel a
little less technical um uh but you know
it it's cool Bluetooth they actually
have it to you it does take you back
though it takes you back to when you
you'd actually build like an IP x XP x
land from scratch yeah to play doom
totally totally and you know and
honestly you know the defining is just
the general presentation the game it
just needs he needs to be just that much
sharper and that much better right it
needs polish much but it looks cute
looks well it's interesting because you
contrast this with something like like
big win baseball and the truth is i'm
not i don't want to make a value
judgment about which game is better
which game is more fun but let's just
talk about packaging the the way that
people feel when they're playing game
you know it's like it's like you you
know you can have two cars that are
equally fast equal is fun to drive but
one's all like rusted out the paint's
all pitted and everything and ones
painted really nicely it just it makes
you feel psychologically difficult earn
off the basketball the blobby volume
I'll card here and i really like the
example is this this this is you can
turn off the blobby volley ball uh card
right now Daniel I'm cuz they're not
looking better more you see you see what
happens one week first week always just
right on the ball totally on the ball
second week just like us hey guys dance
talking yeah whatever I think I'm like
watching something yeah so how are the
young and the restless oh no no you mean
Jen let's be serious a little operas oh
yes so um zu reaction so just by
comparison yeah this is this is tip off
here this is it try this is this is
basketball light here and by contrast
that to what they've done with their new
game in terms of tip off and it's just
yeah you know yes this has a lot of
loading screens but other than that
yuriai I feel like a lot of it is just
going in and getting a designer to work
on the game for about about five days or
less is all it would take I mean they've
done a lot here let's let's let's
no no what no I I realize the
implementation took longer what I'm
saying like if you were I words to go in
with a game a crummy game that we didn't
take it to like Roman Nurik for instance
yes Roman Nurik the Ukrainian yeah and
have him hire an artist uh no i mean he
he would like photo shops and mocks for
us and then we could implement them and
they would look good instead of bad the
way most of our games look yeah my games
so any case yeah the so this is just an
example of a developer who took an
initial game concept which was really
great and took it to the next level with
this really cool polished UI and again
you know that's that's the kind of thing
I need to happen to pop pop volleyball
exactly really good and it just needs to
be taking the next level yeah and you
can tell right you can tell if you're
not at that level if you can't hire
somebody who can yeah it's not I can't
tell if everybody has exactly a you know
a new in my feeling is you know people
say what does it take to get featured
and I said well it takes a great game
that has a good presentation at least a
good presentation it doesn't have to be
a spectacular presentation but you have
to remember your game has to be at that
level you know off the screen here if it
doesn't have that presentation like it
has to be so good it has to be a concept
it's so amazing we have never seen
anything like it it's got you know rave
reviews you know that kind of thing on
the presentation is really important you
know it because remember this reflects
on us right the Google Play team looks
at a game ok we're going to maybe have a
screenshot we're going to have a feature
graphic you know the quality of that
presentation is going to reflect
directly on google play and they're
going to be asking themselves is today's
set of games going to make Google Play
look like a champion or is it going to
make it look like the cigarettes and
pure water store across from my house
right next to the porn dealership and
the check cashing place your house is in
the most awesome location let me just
say that so I'm back this
just think about that is all I'm saying
yeah so you know what you're looking at
is um what are we looking at Wow all
right I mean I'm not gonna put that up
uh so I was a dirty no it said it's so
in there it involve Ollie bolts I don't
even look at this but in Bobby
volleyballs a copy they mentioned that
they're using the paypal library to
allow blood ad-blocking so yes exactly
wait hang up mmm I'm trying to yes what
exactly put that up again we're gonna do
a special segment on this that's a
30-second investigative segment on what
are they doing we added page feature for
blocking ads we need to add permission
to read phone Satan identity used by
paypal library too well in our payments
or ad blocking first of all you're not
allowed to use paper due yet so you guys
by the time you go to look at Bobby
volleyball it may not be there it's very
possible uh yeah yeah that violates our
policy yeah it actually we recently
updated the policy to really clarify
this uh to make it very because a lot of
developers would read to the policy and
they wouldn't understand it right now
it's very clear in the policy so yeah
dude's got switch to using in-app
payments on google play if you're going
to list the game on Google Play yeah
it's just everyone has to use in-app
payments there are a couple of small
exceptions they don't apply to you yeah
I guarantee they do not so use the use
Google Play payments so you know and the
real key thing is again when someone's
looking at the game first of all putting
openfeint pictures in your game in your
I mean that does not make me want it to
go and and download the game right there
at all it makes me actually not want to
download the game no especially the yeah
that the thing with the their list of
what up what are those oh I thought that
was like their tapjoy list or so no like
they're either offer wall no no that's
you know that's just how bad is even
look in open the only and ironically
there is one screen that looks great
here and it's the end game screen it's
not a bad it's
is it isn't and actually what's funny is
at the font weirdly enough looks better
in there screenshots and it does in the
game that I have I'm not sure screenshot
is reduced no no it's not just that look
it's a different font style really yeah
let's see how the fun see it's a larger
wider serif on the font okay well you
know we could talk about this for days
and days let's let's go ahead and call a
moratorium here call an end to this show
yeah but we've looked at some great
sports games um a lot of me oh yes we
have here we have and I and a lot of
games that we did not know about I mean
we've seen the madden so we've seen the
absolutely you know um those are fun
games but it was really cool to see some
smaller indie titles especially that
tip-off basketball how they improved
yeah I think every developer can learn
from that story i'm watchin i'm real i
was really personally excited about
ninja volley i really want to see where
that team goes with that i think that i
think it's a good idea it's a really
good idea it's really cute and I was
also personally I was I you know tip-off
was great star dunk was really fun again
I like I like games that are that have
competitive aspects to it and it was
just awesome I did not know about the
tune Summer Games game and I totally
want to see them just that was really
cute it was totally yeah I want to see
them clean it up I'm really sad that I
didn't find out about that a month ago
yeah you know to be honest because we
would have said all right do this and
this and this of this and then oh yeah
we would have featured it over the
Olympics know lately we would I totally
agree tits oh yeah it's hard I mean the
team here doesn't catch everything that
goes through and so that's part of the
reason we do this show and I kind of
wish we would have done sports last week
but but we did but we had a lot of fun
with racing last week and what's our
next week's show uh next week's show is
a RPGs that's right that's right we're
going to hey what is a mean J or K ok ok
that's right um that's not a joke that's
that's their japanese role-playing games
Korean role-playing games it really any
Pacific Rim role-playing games you know
what we're talking about RPG you can
totally is I I mean you don't know maze
and to make them but yes exactly doesn't
hurt mm-hmm I so the anachronox was kind
of in that model in right ways and it
was still one of my favorites so yeah so
the
yeah the cutesy you know a PlayStation
Portable type of role playing games
there's a ton of them out there a lot of
them come from you only comp to us
always puts one out every few months I
by the way I'm bill I totally want to
see a mobile version of anachronox even
though I know no one has you know no one
useful has the right to that license I
want to see that Mickey game that what
is that call it a king of hearts Oh
kingdom hearts is awesome I was so cool
alright so yeah if you uh if you guys
know of some great Asian and
role-playing games we totally want to
see him at the end here is a huge fan
and I not along and pretend that I
understand what's happening exactly so
will totally go over that next week and
we will see you on the flip side and
it's why I point this out that I that
this is almost gone by the way call
Muskaan see ya this explains so much all
right i mean ii Lewis this is Dan Galpin
Fred no I'm sorry Fred time was nowhere
to be found reto Meier was our producer
Daniel Pham was our engineer and we are
out of here Cheers ipod was empty though
now I say
you